so I am here with Josh Peck hey Josh
Peck from drugged rekha Josh
yes Devin do you know oh yeah yeah I
watched it my friend my friend was like
obsessed with it so like I just watched
it with everyone meet that friend yes we
are here tonight celebrating kids what
was the best part about being a kid oh
my gosh best part about being a kid that
stuff probably being able to eat
whatever I wanted and sure I paid for it
in the long run but while I was doing it
it was great all right nice the
keystrokes it was just all about slime
are you prepared to get so I'm always
ready to get Sam even when I'm not at
the Kids Choice Awards if even if I'm in
my local Chipotle I'm ready to go yeah
nice okay
Congrats on becoming a father what is
the cutest thing your son is done lately
oh my gosh he's like a non-stop cuteness
which is pretty great
but he's already started to appreciate
that song baby shark which is scary but
also amazing yes has Max and John
Stamos's son Billy ever met yet you know
what they met actually
John Stamos brought Billy to the
hospital to meet max so it's really
special I just can't believe I'm friends
with John same high school it was a very
cute moment but let's talk about how I
have famous French you made big news
this week that drake and josh reboot is
in the works with a great idea what can
you tell us about the reboot oh my gosh
well I don't know if it's I wouldn't
call it a reboot I think it's just an
opportunity for drink and I to be
working together again and obviously we
love each other and we were able to make
such an impact on people so any chance
to do something dope together it's
really exciting for me so it's gonna be
good y'all y'all like alright amazing
will these characters will wear both the
characters be when we see them again
I don't know but again it's different
characters so it's gonna be something
new exciting we're trying to go for some
you know like Dean Martin Jerry Lewis
like same guys but in a whole new set of
scenarios
okay um where do you when's the show
premiere
oh I don't know we'll see it's all we
don't know anything you were ahead of
the time all right
that's amazing thank you so much Josh
great job thank you so good